VERY FOUNDATION OF OUR RULE
OF LAW IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA IS IN JEOPARDY.
JOINING US NOW PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY FORMER NEW
YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI.
MR. MAYOR, BEFORE YOU TOOK
ON THIS POSITION YOU HAD ON
THIS PROGRAM IDENTIFIED
CRIMES.
I THINK IT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY RELEVANT HOW
THE YOU WERE ECHELON IN THE
FBI TREATED HILLARY CLINTON
SO SHE COULD SURVIVE WITHOUT
BEING INDICTED AS A
CANDIDATE.
AND HOW THEY HAVE TREATED
DONALD TRUMP AND I DO
BELIEVE THIS IMPACTS WHETHER
OR NOT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AT ITS
FOUNDATION, CONSIDERING IT'S
THE SAME PEOPLE INVOLVED NOW
SHOULD ALL GO AWAY AS A
RESULT.
I WAS ON YOUR SHOW ABOUT A
YEAR AND A HALF WE
IDENTIFIED I THINK IT WAS 18
VIOLATION OF THE LAW BY
HEATHER PICK ABLE TO PROVE
AND IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
WE ARE WAY BEYOND HILLARY
CLINTON.
WE HAVE INVESTIGATION IN THE
WORDS OF PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING HAS BEEN A FIX, A
FRAME-UP AND A WITCH-HUNT.
IT WAS LED BY PETER STRZOK,
WHO IT IS DISGRACEFUL AND
EVEN FOR THE PRESENT
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI TO HAVE
HIM THERE TOMORROW WOULD BE
DISGRACEFUL.
EVERY FBI AGENT SHOULD
DEMAND THAT THAT MAN BE
FIRED AND TOMORROW MUELLER
SHOULD SUSPEND HIS
INVESTIGATION AND THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS
WHO SHOULD NOW STEP UP BIG
TIME TO SAVE HIS DEPARTMENT
SHOULD SUSPEND THAT
INVESTIGATION.
THROW OUT ALL THE PEOPLE IS
THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE PHONY TRUMP
INVESTIGATION AND BRING IN
HONEST FBI AGENTS FROM THE
NEW YORK OFFICE WHO I COULD
TRUST IMPLICITLY AND THEY
SHOULD TURN THEIR ATTENTION
TO COMEY, STRZOK, PAGE, ALL
THOSE FBI AGENTS WHO TOOK
GIFTS -- GIFTS, SEAN?
THAT IS CALLED BRIBERY WHERE
I COME FROM.
THEY TOOK TICKETS THEY PUT
GOVERNOR MCDONALD TO JAIL.
THE ANGRY DEMOCRATS WHO WERE
WORKING FOR MUELLER.
THEY PUT GOVERNOR
MCDAMAGED ON JAIL FOR
TAKING A COUPLE LITTLE
TRINKETS, FBI AGENTS SELLING
OUT AND LEAKING LIKE SOIFS
AND STATEMENT OF STRZOK HE
IS PUT IN CHARGE THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
THE GUY AHEAD OF THIS RICCO
CASE IS JIM COMEY HE CREATED
THIS ATMOSPHERE IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS THE REASON STRZOK AND
PAGE WAS ABLE TO OPERATE.
THOSE GUYS ARE TAKING
TICKETS?
FBI AGENTS SHOULD BE
INFURIATED BY THAT I'M
INFURIATED BECAUSE I LOVE
THE FBI.
THESE PEOPLE DON'T LOVE THE
FBI.
I DO.
>> Sean: I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
PERSON PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS NOT THE RANK AND
FILE.
THIS WAS LITERALLY RIPPED
OUT OF THE HANDS OF RANK AND
FILE.
BROUGHT INTO THE SEVENTH
FLOOR.
THE YOU WERE ECHELON OF THE
FBI.
I GUESS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING HERE IS ESPECIALLY
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND
THE PRESIDENT'S PERSPECTIVE.
IF YOU TREAT ONE CANDIDATE
ONE WAY AND YOU LITERALLY
HAVE CRIMES AND THE EVIDENCE
IS INCONVO VERT TILLABLE.
I NEVER SAW A BETTER CASE
FOR OBSTRUCTION THAN HILLARY
DID FOR DELETING EMAILS,
ACID WASHING AND BREAKING UP
DEVICES.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO TREAT
HER THAT WAY.
AND YOU LOOK AT THE BULLY
TACTICS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
TOGETHER BY WEISSMANN AND
BEGINNING STRZOK AND TEAM
MUELLER PUT TOGETHER, HOW
COULD ANY AMERICAN AT THIS
POINT ENTIRE CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC.
>> I THINK, SEAN, I FEEL
THAT THIS WHOLE THING HAS
MADE FOOLS OF ALL OF US.
I MEAN, THEY THINK WE ARE
IDIOTS.
WE SUPPLIED 1.4 MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
WE SUPPLIED 32 WITNESSES.
NO PRIVILEGE ARGUMENTS.
AND WHO ARE WE SUPPLYING
THEM TO?
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALREADY
CONCLUDED TO FRAME DONALD
TRUMP AGENTS WHO STARTED A
PHONY RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
THIS.
THAT'S WHY THE INVESTIGATION
SHOULD BE SUSPENDED.
AND I AM TALKING FOR MYSELF
NOW, NOT THE PRESIDENT.
BUT I BELIEVE HE WOULD AGREE
WITH THIS.
VERY SERIOUS INVESTIGATION
HAS TO BE DONE OF THE FBI
AGENTS AT THE VERY TOP BY
FBI AGENTS WHO ARE HONEST.
IN ORDER TO PROSECUTE THEM.
>> HATRED THEY HAVE FOR
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S ALL THERE IN BLACK AND
WHITE.
THAT'S POLITICAL.
WHY DID HOROWITZ SAY THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE OF POLITICAL
BIAS WHEN IT'S ALL OVER HIS
DOCUMENT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HOROWITZ
CONCLUDED.
DIRECTOR CONCLUDED.
I'M BEYOND THAT I THINK ALL
THE ATTENTION NOW SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON LET'S GET A FAIR
INVESTIGATION OF THE PEOPLE
WHO CORRUPTED THAT
INVESTIGATION HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN THE CORRUPT
INVESTIGATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID
OVER AND OVER AGAIN TO ME.
DID I NOTHING WRONG.
HOW COULD THIS BE?
NOW WE KNOW HOW IT IS.
BECAUSE, THESE PEOPLE FIXED
IT THAT'S HOW IT IS.
PLEASE, AMERICAN PEOPLE.
READ THIS.
IF YOU ARE NOT DISGUSTED,
AND YOU DON'T -- DEMAND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT BEGIN
THIS INVESTIGATION AND TO
SPEND THE ONE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND ALL THE PEOPLE
TORTURED BY IT, THEN I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE JUSTICE
ANYMORE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Shepard: LAST POINT.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, WE NOW KNOW
IN MEETINGS, HAS THREATENED
TO SUBPOENA EMAILS,
INTIMIDATE, HARASSING
CONGRESSMAN AND THEIR STAFFS
WHO HAVE BEEN TASKED
CONSTITUTIONALLY WITH THE
DUTY OF OVERSIGHT.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THESE THREATS
HE IS THE GUY THAT SIGNED
THE LAST FISA WARRANT
KNOWING THAT THE BULK OF
INFORMATION PHONY CLINTON
PAID FOR DOSSIER AND HE IS
THE GUY WHO RECOMMENDED
FIRING COMEY.
IS HE CONFLICTED.
INTIMIDATING AND THREATENING
TO USE THE POWER OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AGAINST
CONGRESSMAN AND THEIR
STAFFS, WHAT DO YOU CALL
THAT?
TO ME IT SOUNDS LIKE
OBSTRUCTION.
>> YEAH.
IT'S A LOT CLEARER
OBSTRUCTION THAN FIRING
COMEY ON HIS RECOMMENDATION,
WHICH IS NOT OBSTRUCTION.
IT'S WITHIN THE PRESIDENT'S
ARTICLE 2 POWERS.
SO I BELIEVE THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN AND JEFF SESSIONS
HAVE A CHANCE TO REDEEM
THEMSELVES.
THAT CHANCE COMES ABOUT
TOMORROW.
IT DOESN'T GO BEYOND
TOMORROW MUELLER SHOULD BE
SUSPENDED AND HONEST PEOPLE
SHOULD BE BROUGHT IN,
IMPARTIAL PEOPLE TO
INVESTIGATE THESE PEOPLE
LIKE STRZOK.
STRZOK SHOULD BE IN JAIL BY
THE END OF NEXT WEEK.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
MR. MAYOR, THANK YOU.
WE WILL FOLLOW THIS STORY.
>> LET'S SEE IF HE